hey i'm daniel collier and this is how i
became chairman fred hampton
deputy chairman of fredericton of the
illinois black panther party when he was
at the
young patriots you know what a
confederate flag
that was the first day and i was really
nervous and i think
it was something wasn't working the
scene was working and then we managed to
figure out why it wasn't working
i think it was the first time i'd done
the voice and had everything
in in a scene like halfway through the
scene
and then it was just like we'll be okay
because i
i i think i tapped i think that day was
me
shedding the icon-ness of him
and i actually was really embodying him
and um but i had to just kind of wear it
for like half a day in order to um
feel it and then go oh no yeah this fits
let's go
you're saying and um and so that's
that's for me
it was like halfway through the first
day when i i realized i i
i was like oh i'm playing a man who
has a goal and loves
this group of people i will learn all
that i care
in order to give my best and my people
the struggle for liberation there was a
tipping point when when i went to
chicago when i went
by myself to chicago for like a week
that was a tipping point
i wouldn't call it more important than
anything else because i think everything
is as important
as small details but it was a it was a
tipping point in terms of like
cool i feel i'm in here saying but i
think it was just like i needed to get
into that space
and just completely focus on him for a
week um
in order to to understand like yeah no
i i can hear i can i can i can sit in a
certain position
and be a vessel that that i'm aspiring
to be
murdered but you can't matter for you
usually in other process i would have a
collection of people
that i was like this is the area that i
would like oh this this and a bit of
that so i would just listen to
people that i felt like i wanted to have
a vibe of this i would have this fire
and i would go into that direction
and with this i looked for people that
sound similar to chairman fred
and just there wasn't none you know he's
a very distinct
way of speaking and i just had to focus
on him you know but yeah but that what
that gifted me was a
new way of approaching things was that
oh i need to really get into
if speech is a window into how you think
i need to get into thinking in order to
um move in a space of his speech
and so i was like okay cool like like
why does this river make sense why am i
saying this how are the thoughts being
is that how are the new forts igniting
from the fault before you know igniting
in a different way
which is why you're speaking in that way
which is why it's like you see that in a
classroom scene
familiar with like that
he just goes he goes but he can take his
time
but in the turn is bow do you understand
and if that and that's what's quite
um thrilling about the way he speaks
is that and that's that i saw that from
watching him
it's like oh it's like this is this this
and boom
this is this system boom another
direction this is a boom
and like no one can even see that turn
like this is that so in order for me to
i need to process those thoughts in that
ways in order to replicate
the river imagine what we could
accomplish together we can heal this
whole city
i think that's the alarming thing about
i found about chairman fed there was no
comparison
there was no touchstone that i could
kind of go oh i get it
it was like when i read it i said this
is brand new
this is like i have never seen what the
hell is happening here
i've never seen i remember shaka shaka
did
he had two touchstones that he he kind
of thought of
that helped me access the voice actually
was bernie mac
and he then he mentioned richard pryor
it's not something i had internalized
but he was just like saying the command
that they had over an audience
um was similar and i think they're both
illinois maybe yeah both both from
chicago so
and and rich pride was definitely the
era so i know
i found old school richard pryor tapes
and i was listening to that to find if
there was anything that would
feed what was building up when i was in
chicago
i figured out like and i wanted specific
ones but the ones from 1968 69 were like
you can't find them so i know i
i wanted that but then it didn't it
didn't
feed me in that way but it's it's i
think i think knowing that he um
listened to malcolm x and listened to
martin luther king
in the mall in in his regular day in
order to build his um
oratorial abilities gave me a window
into his thinking even more but i
wouldn't compare him
to martin luther king or malcolm x he
kind of
absorbed those ideas and created
something new that's the genius of him
he absorbed all these ideas and created
something original
like original thoughts an original way
they're saying that it's like kind of
like
it hasn't been seen again um in the
public domain
don't say so it was it was more that was
probably the the biggest mountain it was
like i had no touchdown
there was no one i was like oh this is
like this and this is like that like
like i said before like the widow's
character i saw it as bb seagull
you know since i was like boom all right
cool i said i know that i know that way
i don't know and a
little couple of guys i grew up with jon
saying so like i knew like i knew the
world i knew the mentality
in that sense i knew the decision-making
this is not even
it's incomparable
[Applause]
i think it's the shaka lucas brothers
and
wilberson's decision to make it a genre
piece thus
making it accessible for like prime
viewers and thriller watchers and you
know it's like uh
if in that sense because it's kind of
like a similar narrative to
donnie brasco or the departed or you
know
that kind of those kinds of films uh
and so in that sense if someone loves
that sort of narrative they're going to
be drawn upon it and then meet
these what this world and these these um
these politics and these views and these
perspectives and these
how and chairman fred hampton you know
um
so that's that's for me is what um
separates it is that as a genre piece uh
we mean in genre as opposed to
as opposed to just about it being about
um educating and informing them
about the black panther party um it it's
kind of what did it what did ryan and
shaka say um
he put them put the medicine in the food
it's um it's how they saw it
when i dedicated my life to the people i
dedicated my life i think it was a 50
year anniversary that day
we did a poison scene and then the scene
that
where chairman fred makes a certain
decision and
i found that day personally really
to find the truth get out of my own way
get out my
my emotions were flaring up they're
saying so i wasn't clear
like i realized how entangled i'm
enmeshed i was
to this and i really felt some real
things
and it was kind of like stopping me from
accessing the truth in the way i usually
access it
and so it was kind of it was more it was
more of that it was that i found
um i found that really challenging to to
to find the way that i weighed the way i
usually find it
anyway there's people is power
i think shaka said today is like you
can't
what o'neill isn't shows you what fred
is
chairman fred is i think i think it was
he says it way more articulate than i
just
i just said it i'm gonna text him after
and ask it for a specific quote
but um but uh and yeah so i think it's
that it's like you can't appreciate the
light without the dark
that's just life that's just truth
that's law so i think we were both in
service of chairman fred is the reality
you know and i think uh i've heard la
keith articulate that for himself
in order to access what he the debts and
places that he had to go to
um so and and yeah i think we just
kind of sat in that truth and um and
supported each other on days that we
needed
to support when certain days where he
had to do some
some really intense stuff i was there
y'all went what do you need and one of
those days
i need to do it internet stuff he was
that like yeah yeah damn what you need
so it kind of moved like that the black
panthers are forming a rainbow coalition
of oppressed brothers and sisters of
every color
you